looking very dapper good morning and
happy new year i'm adriana diaz
millions around the world said good
writtens to 2020
with some very different new year's eve
celebrations the streets of times square
were virtually empty as the ball dropped
without a hitch
crowds were prohibited under covet
restrictions the annual fireworks on the
las vegas strip were canceled
but one hotel had a smaller pyrotechnic
show and despite a ban on public
gatherings
thousands of people outside zimbabwe's
capitalist capital celebrated at a new
year's concert the new year begins with
ugly new numbers in the coronavirus
pandemic u.s officials reported more
than 3 700 deaths yesterday
bringing the total number to more than
345
thousand this morning u.s hospitals are
handling more than 125
coveted cases in los angeles county one
of every five coronavirus tests is
coming back positive
los angeles mayor eric garcetti told our
carter evans
that the outbreak's darkest days are
still ahead
the governor said hospitalizations in
california could double in the next
month
how can la hospitals handle twice as
many patients
the simple answer is we can't that will
be that worst case scenario in which
care is rationed who gets the oxygen who
gets the equipment who gets the bed
it will be the most horrible vision of
what we
have sought to avoid covet
hospitalizations in la are up more than
190 percent
in the last month